الامم المتحده تحذر من تضاعف عدد ضحايا
الزلزال اجسام مجهوله تستنفر امريكا وكندا
تركيا تعتقل 130 مقاولا على خلفيه انهيار
بعض المباني هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها
لكم من قناه العربيه فاهلا بكم
مع تجاوز حصيله ضحايا الزلزال المدمر في
تركيا وسوريا اكثر من 55 الف وفاه حذر
مساعد الامين العام للامم المتحده للشؤون
الانسانيه مارتني جريث من ان حصيله
الوفيات ربما ستتضاعف جرفث قال انه من
الصعب تقييم الحصيله النهائيه للقتل بدقه
مع مواصله فرق الانقاذ البحته عن جينا تحت
انقاض المباني المدمره واصفا زلزال بانه
اسوا كارثه في هذه المنطقه منذ 100 عام
على الاقل
بعد ايام على حادث المنطاد الصيني اعلنت
كل من الولايات المتحده وكندا اسقاط جسمين
غريبين كان يحلقان في اجوائهما وفيما
اسقطت مقاتله امريكيه جسما مجهولا بحجم
سياره صغيره حلق فوق الاسكا بالقرب من
الحدود الكنديه اعلن الرئيس الوزراء
الكندي جاستن برودو اسقاط جسم اخر وصفه
بغير المحدد رصد يحلق شمال كندا على
ارتفاع حوالي 40 الف قدم ويجري الان جمع
حطام الجسمين وتحليل اجزائهما وفحصها
وبالعوده الى اخبار الزلزال اعتقلت
السلطات التركيه 130 مقاولا من متعهدين
بناء بسبب عيوب ومخالفات ادت الى انهيار
بعض المباني وفيما اعلن وزير البيئه
والتطوير العمرانيه التركيه ان عددا مباني
المنهاره او المتضرره بشكل كبير بين عموم
المباني المنكوبه بلغ
141 مبنا باشرت السلطات التركيه تحقيقات
موسعه حول المخالفات العمرانيه في جميع
المناطق التي ضربها زلزال
مفضلا عدم الكشف عن هويته تبرع رجل اعمال
باكستاني مقيم في الولايات المتحده بمبلغ
30 مليون دولار لضحايا الزلزال المدمر في
تركيا وسوريا رئيس الوزراء الفلسطينيه قال
ان رجلا باكستانيا مجهولا دخل الى السفاره
التركيه في الولايات المتحده وتبرع بمبلغ
30 مليون دولار لضحايا زلزال مؤكدا تشكيل
لجنه وزاريه خاصه للاشراف على جمع الاموال
ومواد الغذاء بل الاغاثه وضمان تسليمها في
الوقت المناسب الى المناطق التي دمرها
الزلزال
وفي خضم ماساه الزلزله التي تعيشها سوريا
قتل عشره مدنيين اضافه الى عنصر من قوات
النظام في هجوم شنه وتنظيم داعش وسط
البلاد عناصر التنظيم هاجموا نحو 75 شخصا
بينما كانوا يعملون في جمع الكماه في
منطقه تدمر بريف حمص الشرقي ما ادى الى
مقتل عشره مدنيين منهم بينهم امراه اضافه
الى عنصر من قوات النظام فيما لا يزال
الاخرون في عداد المفقودين بحسب ما اعلن
المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان